are people really fleeing their home
countries to get to one of the 40 least
peaceful Nations on Earth according to
the 2023 Global Peace Index they are I
rate the U.S 131st out of 163 countries
lower than Haiti El Salvador Cuba and
Guatemala but we know the U.S isn't less
peaceful than these countries because
citizens of these places regularly risk
their lives to come to the United States
for a better future so why does the US
rank so low well the Global Peace Index
has a bias it doesn't like large armies
or big weapons reserves and the US has
both you can fault America for having an
oversized military but don't believe
these rankings citizens from places like
Haiti are fleeing violence and risking
everything to come here